el poder adquisitivo ha sido el tema
central de la elección las encuestas
muestran que es la principal
preocupación entre los votantes casi
todos los candidatos proponen una
revalorización general de los salarios y
especialmente del mínimo pero tienen
opciones divergentes con respecto al
ingreso de solidaridad activa conocido
en francia como rsf es una ayuda del
estado de alrededor de 550 euros al mes
de la cual cada persona mayor de 25 años
puede beneficiarse si tiene bajos
ingresos unos quieren mantenerlo pero
condicionarlo mientras que otros quieren
crear una renta mínima de alrededor de
mil euros al mes garantizada por el
estado la gran mayoría de los candidatos
también proponen instaurar una pensión
mínima para los jubilados pero lo que
difiere son sus propuestas sobre la edad
legal de jubilación que actualmente está
establecida en 62 años en cuanto a la
seguridad todos los candidatos menos
philippe utu proponen aumentar los
efectivos policiales la guerra en
ucrania reactivó el debate sobre la otan
y las políticas de inmigración en contra
la alianza atlántica las posturas son
diversas piden seguir en ella
abandonarla o solo abandonar el comando
integrado que es el que fija las
estrategias militares al respecto al
tema de la inmigración la izquierda
generalmente propone acoger migrantes
bajo mejores condiciones y regularizar
la situación de las personas en
condición irregular mientras que los
candidatos de derecha buscan establecer
cuotas de inmigración o endurecer el
acceso al permiso de residencia y hasta
la expulsión de los extranjeros sin
papeles para la extrema derecha mientras
que en el otro extremo
natalia esto y filippo tu quieren
permitir la libre circulación de los
migrantes la crisis del cobi 19 llevó a
repensar el sistema hospitalario casi
todos los candidatos pro pueden aumentar
el número de camas en los hospitales y
aumentar los salarios para el personal
de la salud
finalmente el medio ambiente sigue
siendo un tema importante cada candidato
tiene propuestas para luchar contra el
calentamiento global pero los candidatos
se dividen sobre la cuestión nuclear la
mayoría de la electricidad francesa está
producida por las centrales nucleares lo
que permite reducir la dependencia de
los combustibles fósiles pero éstas
representan un riesgo medioambiental y
un costo financiero